[Music]
Hollywood's most powerful ladies all in
one room Kelsey honestly I looked to the
left and I was like icon right icon this
was such an inspiring moment from
Angelina Jolie to Jennifer Lawrence The
Hollywood Reporter's women in
entertainment power 100 event
celebrating females in this industry
girl come all the way power was clearly
more meaningful in this climate than
ever before and even the men represented
starting with Justin Timberlake
[Music]
you know that Justin Timberlake just
walked by yes girl cuz I saw it I'm
gonna think of a winning I mean he's
just a bomb how much do we love JT
showing love for strong women including
keynote speaker Angelina who shared a
sweet story about her kid struggles
listening and doing last-minute homework
and listening and debating the
importance of brushing teeth I actually
did debate some teeth brushing this
morning I lost I was raised by a strong
woman I was lucky enough to convince a
strong woman to marry me she got
nominated for a Critics Choice today
shadow as I look out at everyone here
today and Justin Timberlake I'm reminded
let's be outspoken let's be resilient
let's all be silenced breakers j-law
received the events big Leadership Award
she's the magazine's cover girl this
week interviewed by Oprah Winfrey
Jennifer turned serious about
empowerment so many people are are
listening and watching they have a
responsibility
what a great event it was fabulous I
gotta say a shout-out to Lea Michele who
we saw earlier in our show when she
arrived on the red carpet she was
shaking holding my hand she had just
evacuated her house and mica said you
know this keeps me going this is the
most important event of the year all
these women and I had to be here which
is really fabulous and I want to mention
that because of the road closures and
safety concerns due to these wildfires
in LA Kim kardashian-west Kendall Jenner
and Selena Gomez didn't make it to the
event yeah it was crazy I mean LA is
pretty crazy it's kind of go down a
little bit really it's know their houses
are safe we do want to say that that's
good
[Music]